My sister just died in 527 with all his power and so far as we know peacefully.
And was succeeded in the tyranny over Athens by his sons by his first wife.
Hippies.
Who was the elder and hip parkas.
I think it's it's reasonable to think it's proper to think of hippies as the man
in charge but hip Farkas shared a considerable amount of his power and
responsibility.
At first.
It appears that they ruled in the same way that their father had which was to
say one that was moderate and didn't cause a great deal of opposition.
In Athens.
And of course there always was a certain amount of opposition and we should not
forget that aristocratic families always vying for their own power and their own
position were uncomfortable very often under a price Judas and different ones.
Different families got into trouble and were driven out and our old friends the
alchemy on it I got into trouble again were banished.
In the time of the sons of my sisters and it was necessary to fight to have a
battle against them in which they were defeated and driven out.
I will play a significant role in the future of Athens quite soon but I think
it's in the year 5 14 that a very important event changes the course of things.
There is a personal quarrel between the tyrants one of the tyrants actually and
one of the noble young men which results in a plot to kill both hippies and hip
parkas led by two young men who will become known in feet in law as the
tyrannosaur sides because in their plot they succeed in killing the younger
brother hip pockets although they don't get hippy as they themselves are killed.
The plot fails but its significance I think comes in the fact that it made
hippies thereafter very nervous very concerned about his safety and about the
future of his regime and the nature of the regime according to tradition changes
and it becomes very harsh and there are
prosecutions of people who are suspected of perhaps plotting who are hoping to
plot against the tyranny and that's significant and that's a characteristic
event as I told you early on as I spoke about tyranny in general.
Usually in the second and sometimes if they made it to the third there would be
opposition.
The opposition would make the rulers nervous the nervous rulers would then
misbehave and create further opposition.
And that's the story as it happens in Athens.
One wrinkle in the Athenian story is that the
alchemy on a guy who had been expelled from the city always active always
thinking
became got into a position of especial favor to the Delphic oracle.
When there was an earthquake that badly damaged the temple of Apollo at Delphi
the alchemy on died bid for the contract to rebuild rebuild the temple and in
the doing of that they spent some of their own money to make the temple even
more beautiful than the contract required which put them in great favor with the
priests of Delphi and they immediately cash this favor in in the form of seeking
their own political advantage.
The story as Herodotus tells it is that their goal was to drive out happiness
from Athens and the way to do it this time.
Remember they've tried every trick in the world and it hasn't really work.
And the idea now is to turn to the most powerful military state in Greece and
use it for their purposes.
I'm talking of course about Sparta and the tale is that whenever the Spartans
sent a message to the Delphic oracle asking for an opportunity consult the
oracle.
The answer that came back was first free the Athenians.
Well whether that was the reason or he had reasons of his own the very ambitious
King of Sparta King Clay hominids was going to undertake the job of removing
hippies from power in Athens quite soon.
It's in the year five eleven ten that the Spartans under clear nominees will
invade Attica gain control of the state and remove hippies and withdraw.
But we'll come back to that story in just a moment.
Let me conclude our consideration of the Athenian tyranny by looking at what
were the achievements and consequences of the years of tyrannical rule.
Many positive elements as was so often the case with tyranny from the economic
side.
This was a period of great expansion of Athenian commerce trade very strong to
the east through the hell respond and to the Black Sea but also in this period.
Athens trades very strongly with the West.
I meant to say chiefly Sicily and Italy and in fact up to that point up to those
years roughly speaking currency and pottery fine currency and pottery is
dominant in the western areas is no surprise that's always been the case for a
currency but by the end of the sixth century Athenian pottery has actually
outstripped that in the Western markets which show you how much this combination
of trade industry was changing the character of Athens and making it wealthier
and bringing along various elements that of change in their way of life.
Another consequence of the tyrannical experience in Athens was a diminution in
the power of the aristocracy.
And this again the general story wherever we see tyranny in the Greek world it
never erases aristocracy you never see the disappearance of the distinction
between nobles and commoners and claims to the aristocracy of birth and descent
from the gods.
It's always there.
And even in the most democratic of Athenian of Greek states like Athens for
instance it did an aristocracy doesn't go away.
It's not abolished.
It live side by side with a democratic constitution.
But the DUP the domination by the aristocracy the monopoly of all the powers and
influence that they used to have.
It's not there and that is a tremendously important consequence so that when the
tyranny goes away and it's necessary to reconstruct a New Athenian constitution
the answer will not simply be a return to the old days before the tyrants so
long had intervened in an important way.
And the tyrants had made their contribution to to changes that turned out to be
permanent.
It's also true that under the tyrants the local power of the noblemen had been
reduced and the power of the government in Athens which was not dominated by the
aristocracy but by the tyrants that was a trend and one of the issues that would
have to be worked out would be what would be the relationship between the
localities outside of Athens and the city itself.
Localism has been damaged but not abolished.
If there are going to be new forms of government that take place one of the
consequences one of the things I should say when the precursors of that will be
to further strengthen the centre and weaken the periphery and to continue to
strip as best one could the influence and power of the aristocracy which was
mainly to be felt in the countryside and to increase the power of some other
form of government which centre would be in Athens.
On the other hand because of the reforms of so long which I remind you by
sisters and his sons allowed to stay in place at least in the formal sense
because therefore every year.
Think about it.
People were elected Aachen people were chosen for a council.
Law Courts operated all of these things not dominated by the aristocracy but
really in the case of the magistracy as the wealth.
Was the criterion Remember ever since so long.
So that people who were not aristocrats but were wealthy also participated in
those jobs and the council which was open to three out of the four Athenian
classes under so long meant that people actually went to the council chamber
participated in decisions about what was going on to be sure they weren't going
to do anything that the tyrants didn't want but nineteen ninety five percent of
the time may be more tyrant didn't care so that they were getting.
This is the point I really want to stress.
They were getting experience in the business of self-government.
And when you do that I think the history of the world shows that once people
have risen to that state where they do participate in their own self-government
it's very hard to get them back into a state when they don't anymore.
That's going to be very difficult to make stick.
Athens has been moved down the road to self-government as a consequence.
Strangely enough of the tyranny just in passing I might point out that's not a
unique phenomenon.
It's very interesting to look back at the early post colonial age in the 20th
century and to see that there were real differences between colonies that had
been ruled in.
I would want to say tyrannical way but in an absolute way such as the Congo or
other places like that as opposed to places that had achieved some degree of
self-government even while they were ruled by a European power.
The difference was very great.
Once you have the same experience that I'm talking about now that led to the
capacity and a determination to govern oneself was more likely in places where
there had been some such thing.
India of course is a striking example where the Indians had managed to achieve
some degree of participation in the government of their own state under the
British who in spite of all the troubles they had have actually produced a
functioning relatively democratic government in that great subcontinent.
Well that's the sort of thing I'm talking about.
So.
Knowing what we now know looking backward is possible to say it looks like the
tyranny played a very important role in the transition from aristocratic
government to democracy.
That's not what the tyrants intended they intended to rule for as long as they
could.
But it was one of the consequences as we will see.
Well let's turn once again to those me on a day who had as you remember a
checkered past in Athens and even under the tyranny because they had been driven
out.
Remember mega Cleese had had his deal with my sister this had broken that
position is that broken that deal so he went into opposition.
He and the army and I had driven out but they came back because we find Christ
in his name on the list of our cons but then they had been driven out again and
in the year five eleven ten Kleist Denise who was leader of the alchemy and had
family and political faction was in exile and was working to get the Spartans to
do the job that was done so please Minnie's takes his Spartan army in and 510 he
drives out the tyrants and then he goes home.
Now the question that confronts the Athenians is what form of government should
we have.
And again there's there's a whole range of possibilities not a whole range or a
few possibilities that one would be reactionary.
Let's go back to the days before so long when the aristocracy was everything.
There certainly as we will see where people who wanted to do something very much
like that.
On the other hand what are you going to do about all these people of consequence
who are wealthy and who have made it to the top of the were not aristocrats and
then what are you going to do about all of these family farmers of whom there
must be more now than ever because of the.
My suggestion that by system this had taken away land from some exiled
aristocrats and distributed among families some of whom were successful on farms
and became hotplate soldiers and independent farmers they're not going to be
enjoy being put back to a position which was worse than they had under the
tyranny because under the tyranny they were sitting on councils and
participating in these things and sitting in courts and now there's ever gonna
be take all this was going to be taken away if the reactionary aristocracy had
its way.
That was really what the contest was.
I think it should.
Should we continue with the colonial constitution only without tyrants or should
we go back to an aristocracy and the contest for how to decide that was done in
the usual old fashioned way.
That is to say in the contest for the arcane ship the candidates on of holding
one view ran against candidates holding the other view and that's where the
matter would be sited be decided.
But they went at it in the old way.
That is the decisions were being made in the political clubs that belonged to
the aristocracy.
In other words how we're going to do this was being fought out.
In the with among the aristocrats not among the public at large.
And in that contest
place the names who stood for the more moderate for the colonial let us say
approach as his family had always done lost.
The winner was a man called ISAC Iris an aristocrat.
They were all of us to crash of course and he engages the I should say by the
way we're talking now.
This court this election takes place after a preliminary pushing back and forth
in the year 5 0 8 7
and his victory means a victory for the reactionary program and one of his first
actions is to establish still another council not the Council of 400 that so
long had established but a new council of 300 and it was to be made up only of
aristocrats second.
Very interesting and it turns out very important change introduced by ISAC which
was to scrutinise the citizens list and then to remove from that list.
Lots and lots of people who were deemed to be.
I guess to say illegally enrolled in the citizen list.
They were now going to impose retroactively the traditional criterion for
Athenian citizenship is your father an Athenian citizen.
But we know that Solon had already broken through that by permitting people to
come to Athens and to acquire citizenship if they had the necessary skills.
And there surely had been a fair number of those.
And we are told that the PI system heads had done the same thing for pretty much
the same reason.
So over a couple of generations you had foreigners coming to Athens and
acquiring Athenian citizenship and undoubtedly using it who are now going to be
disenfranchised and driven from the citizen lists.
Now that made for quite a few discontented people in Athens if you if you picked
a moment after which I sacrifice has accomplished these two things.
That is establishing the Council of 300 which is obviously going to be the
governing body in Athens and aristocratic council and driven X number of people
from the citizen lists.
Then all of those people are going to be very unhappy and very likely they have
friends who are also going to be unhappy.
So you have a situation which is by no means calm and subtle but it might have
settled down as people as they usually do when things are unavoidable when there
is no real option.
Nobody is making a different case.
They would have just gotten used to things I suppose but now Clyde Sinise
decides to do things differently.
He does not accept his defeat as he would have had to do in the old days having
been defeated in the aristocratic contest instead in the words of Herodotus
prose that reads it I tongue.
Damon He brought the people into his political faction the root of that first
word processor reads a tie his head tie Rhea which means a club a political club
a collection of companions.
That's the name for these aristocratic societies and and Kleist and these broke
the rules.
He went out there beyond the aristocratic circle and he recruited people you'll
become part of my political faction.
Well why should they.
Because he had a program that was contrary to the one pursued by high salaries.
It's one that will result when it is successful in the establishment of what
pretty much everybody agrees was the first Athenian democracy.
The reforms that he proposed then we have we have to imagine he actually went
around an election year that was not done before that and persuaded people to
support him in his programs and then he put his programs through.
Well where did he put these programs through.
He surely couldn't have done that in the Council of 300 it would never have
passed any.
I'm sure you didn't try.
Instead he acted I think as though there was no council of 300.
He did what you would have done if you wanted to propose a bill prior to that
you would go you would go to the assembly which was the slowness in assembly and
which had the right to pass laws no doubt.
It only passed laws that the price district is wanted but it was not something
new.
It was something people were accustomed to.
And he went to the Assembly and he proposed his laws and they were passed.
Well I Sacker was still had the whip hand and he wasn't going to sit still while
that took place.
And so using the force at his disposal he drove clear.
I'm sorry.
It's matter of fact the force that I was at was at his disposal was that of
tinkling nominees and the Spartans who came back again when called back.
No doubt what Clemens had in mind when he did what he had done originally
driving out the price district it was the establishment of an aristocratic
republic in Athens with his friends being in charge.
That's what the Spartans typically would do if they could.
So he was shocked and annoyed.
I'm certain when he hears his friends have been somehow pushed out of power and
some new fangled kind of a government that lets ordinary people participate has
been instituted.
So calamities comes back with his forces and drives Kleist and his and we are
told this is interesting figure.
I can't promise that it's right but it does show up in Athens and Herodotus
licenses and seven hundred families who must have been in his faction are driven
out of Abbot out of out of Attica.
But the people are not ready to take that.
They resist and they have numbers on their side and they end up shutting up clay
hominids and his forces which are not many.
We're talking about probably hundreds of soldiers no more than that.
And we must imagine that there are thousands of Athenians out there who are
discontent.
So they shut Clay nominees up on the Acropolis where he has run for safety with
salaries at his side.
And finally they cut a deal and they go home and Kleist and his and his
supporters who it's fair I think to start calling Democrats have taken over the
city by this coup and are ready to go forward now this requires that they
establish a new constitution because they're going to have a regime the likes of
which no one had ever seen before.
But in trying to understand this constitution and it's not easy.
The ancient sources tell us a lot about it but it's not perfectly clear what's
in everybody's mind as they do what they do.
Motives purposes are not clear as you'll see in a moment.
But anyway what I want you to a fix on is this.
Don't imagine that what's taking place here is even anything like the American
Constitutional Convention in Philadelphia where a bunch of delegates have been
selected from here and there and they all sit and argue with each other over the
hot summer and finally come up with various plans.
It's better I think to think we're using historical analogies to help us as of
course there is nothing better than that to help us.
Think of the French Revolution.
Think of the convention where the sort of the mass of the people have gained
control of the situation after driving the king from his throne and after really
putting aside a more aristocratic council that came before it and they sit down
with radical people running around ready to kill people.
This is the outfit that's going to end up killing the King and his queen and all
the aristocrats they can lay their hands on.
In other words we are in a revolutionary situation and their force and terror.
Are in the air and everybody is fully aware of the danger of this that and the
other thing and of some dangers that probably don't even exist.
We are in a situation that resembles civil war that could be on the brink of a
serious civil war.
And added to that.
In other words the Athenians who are who will be sitting in the assembly passing
the laws that produce the Constitution that Kleist in these favors are first of
all already afraid that the local aristocrats will use force or guile against
them.
But on top of that there's been two Spartan invasions of Attica in the last
couple of years and this is nothing to stop.
King Clay nominees from coming back again because he doesn't like the way he's
been treated.
In fact I'd go further I'd say there's every reason to fear that that's going to
happen again.
That's where the analogy to the French Revolution works again because nothing
that happens in that the most radical period of the French Revolution is
understandable if you don't know that the French regularly expect that the kings
and emperors of Europe will be marching against them with professional armies
very soon and their fear is absolutely justified and so is the Athenian fear
that the Spartans will be coming.
So it's in that hot environment where fear is all over the place that this new
democratic constitution will be shaped
and there's no question that I think that the place where it's happening is in
the Assembly.
The Assembly sits as you I hope you know on a hillside in the middle of Athens
on a hill called the panics and there in the open air all adult male citizens
are eligible to participate in what takes place.
One little point I also suggest to you is what about the people who have been
thrown off the citizen lists.
Are they there.
My No.
This is just reasoning I don't we don't have any hard evidence.
My my my answer is absolutely they are.
Who is going to tell them not to you show up on the Hill.
Who's going to kick you off.
This Kleist Dems want you kicked out.
Hell no.
Because as we will see one of his main planks is enrolling those people as
citizens.
So in fact I will bet a lot of money that in all the electioneering that went on
about all these different things they were a group he must have targeted and say
you you've been unfairly treated by these aristocrats.
If I get in power I will see to it that you are enrolled again as citizens.
So all of that is happening and people are very excited about what is going on.
That's the background for these rather dry and puzzling details I am about to
lay on you to try to describe what this new what these new laws were that
amounted to some kind of a democracy.
At the center of them apparently were reforms of the tribes and they are in some
ways very radical indeed.
As you note these tribes go back.
Before the birth of history.
Think of any primitive society you want to it's likely to be divided up into
tribes the tribes typically are alleged to come from some very ancient times
when gods or heroes founded them.
That's certainly true of the Greek tribes where each tribe is named after some
heroic figure or some semi divine figure in the past.
So there are for the four traditional Ionian tribes and that's why this what
makes it even more radical than anything else is that class in these law.
Changes the tribal system in Athens from four tribes to ten tribes absolutely
brand new things that have no tradition behind them nothing.
No history or anything and then he has to give names to these tribes and
according to the Greek practice these tribes have to have some founding hero to
be named after so he gets picks out.
I think I'm right in thinking 100 names of heroes and he assigns them to the ten
tribes by lot and now we suddenly have ten new tribes now.
I mean if you trick and try to think yourself back.
To tribal society and think What a what a disruptive thing this is all my life
I've been a member of the tribe named after iron.
And some of my ancestors and so my answer no more.
He's not around anymore.
There's a new tribe that was just invented that I'm a member of.
So that's a very surprising thing but that's not the end of the story.
Each tribe now is divided up into three parts.
They the word for a third is treatise and the plural is treatise.
And here's the point.
Each one of each tribe has one of its treaty ace in and around the city of
Athens.
It has another one in the middle of Athens.
And I'm sorry in the middle of Attica and in the third it is the third of its
three regions sorry of its of its three divisions will be in the region called
the coast that Kerala.
So every tribe is geographically distributed across all of Africa in this way.
That is something quite new in the old days.
We have to believe that the tribes were geographically separated for regions for
tribes.
Yeah.
The Sydney region the Coast region and the Midland Region.
Each one of these regions has 10 treaties one for each of the 10 tribes.
Now let's take it a step further.
The treaties themselves are formed of units that are called deems in English.
That's DTM yes the Greek word for it.
Very confusing is de MOS now the day MOS is this deemed this political unit.
It also means a village.
It also means the whole Athenian people.
And it also means only the poor Athenian people.
So there you are.
But in the context that we're dealing with it here we mean these units that are
geographical and have a constitutional function.
There is however even here there's a certain amount of.
Confusion because some of the deems are actually made up of an original village.
They don't mess with that.
Diem is the equivalent of.
In other words a Diem is a dean the two different meanings of the word.
The other deems for the constitutional purpose are made up of a number of
villages.
So there would be a lot of these old deans placed into the new constitutional
deal.
The idea however is that every treatise must be of the same size in terms of
population because they have your whole idea is to get each tribe to be
numerically equal and that's one reason for that is because the tribes will be
the regiments of the Athenian army.
You line up and fight in.
When that when you're call to fight in the Army in your accordance with your
Diem which is located in a certain tradition which is becomes a regiment of your
tribe as a regiment of the army now.
They get to straighten out the deems are unequal in population but the trivia
Ace has to be equal.
So that tells you you have to have multiple teams in some and just one or two or
not or a few in another.
All right.
It is also true that the treaties are assigned to the tribes by lot.
And the thing I want you to remember I want to avoid as much complication as I
can is that it doesn't really matter to the people who invented the Constitution
how the Diems are assigned to the treaties except one scholar has suggested one
motive that strikes most of us as very plausible made a careful study of how the
themes are distributed to the treaties
and compared them with where we know there were important religious sites.
You know the Greek religion has these many gods and deities and they have local
characteristics because there are legends about their having lit on this earth
at a certain place or done a deed at another place.
So you have a cave of hand in eastern Attica and you have a place where Athena
did this that and the other thing.
And the point I'm getting at is these became shrines places where the religion
was exercised and in ancient Attica aristocratic Attica the aristocrats owned a
piece of land on which the shrine was which meant you had to have their
permission to come onto it to worship which meant that they would have
predominance power and influence in these areas.
Well what does scholar David Lewis was his name.
Concluded was that there are times when there are quite a few times when the
thing is laid out in such a way as to decide the divide.
The religious site on the aristocrats.
Land.
From his main dwelling on that land.
So the aristocrat is separated from the place where he has religious clout as a
way of dividing up his political influence and power.
He reads this as a one of the ways in which class Sunnis attempted to diminish
the power of the aristocracy through its local influence.
Now this new deem is very very important.
It is the basic unit in the whole system it takes.
It was meant I should say to take the place of the frat tree.
You remember the Brotherhood that was the kernel of the old tribal system.
It was meant that the frat tree that the Dean should be the basic thing for
instance
one of the most important things was that your citizenship according to the laws
of class and these were no longer was no longer to be ascertained by going to
your frat tree.
But each Dean would keep an official role of the citizens in that deed.
So when an Athenian boy is born and when he reaches a certain age you have to
take him to the Diem and register him and now he can be an Athenian citizen.
Well this was one of several things that we see in Christ in his constitution
that.
In which the intention could not be carried out.
That is the flattery and the notion of the flattery as the core of such things
was never abolished would have been out out out of the question to abolish it
that too many religious associations and it never really lost its place in the
Athenian mind.
Yes your official enrollment as a citizen was in the dream but there was still a
tremendous allegiance to the flattery.
So it didn't have its end and the factory was still run by aristocrats so it
didn't have its full effect
the Diem elected an official called a D Mark.
We could might call a mayor or whatever the local official is called selectmen.
We say sometimes still in Connecticut holding to our colonial traditions.
And the demon is also given religious functions and religious rights because
everybody knows that religion still is potent.
Even if you're engaged in a revolution in Athens at the beginning of the fifth
century
here's another thing that they tried to do.
Kaizen is tried with a law to change the way in which an Athenian was officially
designated.
It used to be before classes came along.
You ask a man who are you.
He would say I am Kleist and he's the son of mega Cleese period.
Just the petro Nemec just like you know
you have you bear the name of your father unless you chose to bear the name of
your mother which is evidence of how on the theman we really are.
So that's the way it was.
But under the laws of Christ and His henceforth citizens were to be designated
not as Christ in the son of mega Cleaves but as Kleist Denise from Alo picky
which is to say his Diem he was to be the citizen's name and his Diem name it
was a direct
people have argued about what the point of all this was but I think one limited
point before we get to the full story is simply another way of cutting down the
influence of birth in this society as a way of damaging the aristocratic
principle and asserting in its place look what's really happening here that
there is something which is the poles that has nothing to do with birth that is
the part of the legal structure which is a pole is it's a whole new concept
that's really creeping in here replacing the old traditional way of organizing
society with one that is the work of citizens coming together and determining
how they themselves will be governed.
All right let that be the story of the tribes for a moment now.
Here we go with another council.
You've heard about the Council of 400.
You've heard about the Council of 300.
We can do better than that.
We can have a council of five hundred.
It will be the council that is the Democratic Council for the remainder of the
history of the Athenian democracy with the exception of short periods of
oligarchic rebellion that remove it but it comes back when the democracy does
and that council let me simply describe it very briefly.
It is open to all Athenian adult male citizens.
Membership on the council comes through some combination of allotment and
election.
The
point that the point of it is that an assembly of thousands is not well-equipped
to conduct all kinds of business that has to be conducted for the state and even
its own business.
You need a small group to prepare the agenda for a full assembly meeting and so
that was the function of the 500.
It is and this is very important one of those very democratic elements in the
assembly of course is totally democratic because all adult male citizens
participate if they wish.
But you can easily get around that in some degree if you have a counselor little
group that actually determines what's going to happen from the first.
It wasn't so the the members of the council had to be
I'm sorry the council itself was as democratic as the assembly and so we'll come
back to that council later on but there it is in place.
Another thing that happened not in 5 0 8 7 but a few years down the road but
still in this same period was that by now the army of Athens which originally
had been led simply by the Parliament.
The icon who was chosen for the military leadership he had given way to generals
who commanded the different tribes.
And it used to be that each tribe elected its own general.
But in the new system now each tribe sorry back up.
The entire people elected the generals for each of the tribes.
In other words the ten tribes still had a general apiece but the entire
population elected him usually play.
He came from the tribe that he was asked to command but not always.
And again this you can see what the point of this is.
It has the same characteristic as so much of what we are describing it is going
to reduce this particular schism localism and make the whole people the whole
demos and their representative institutions be the decisive element in the state
and that is one of the things as well we'll be getting to right next to ask
ourselves what's going on here and why is it happening.
And here's where our sources.
I'll tell you what our sources say and that's the end of the day we have to make
some judgments of course.
Generally and I think properly the source get who gets the most credence from
scholars today is Herodotus who's closer to it in time than although he's
buying.
You know I should point out here right if this is writing his history some time
or at least he's writing it as late as the four twenties but he himself goes
back to an earlier part of the 5th century and therefore he is in a position to
hear stories from people who go back even into the 6th century which makes him
theoretically a more credible source than people like Aristotle who I'll be
quoting at you who lives in the 4th century and has a good hold century later
than Herodotus.
But Herodotus is not of course himself a witness to any of the facts that he
abuses anyway he asks Why did Clay cities of Athens do what he did.
And his answer is a pretty stale one.
He was trying to copy his ancestor Kleist the knees of sticking on who also
changed the tribes.
You may remember in second from the old Dorian tribes two new tribes that
designated the wrong people like I mean to say the Dorian's as swine men and
asked men and so on.
And that that's why closely is that any sort of be a nice thing to do because
his ancestors namesake did the same thing.
Well I don't think we can buy that.
We move into a more persuasive territory.
I think when we get to Aristotle who writes in his politics as follows perhaps a
question rather arises.
He's dealing with the whole question of citizenship about those who had been
admitted to citizenship after a revolution had taken place for instance such a
creation of citizens as that carried out at Athens by Kleist Denise after the
expulsion of the tyrants when he enrolled in his tribes many resident aliens
medics who had been foreigners and slaves.
So here's a new story we have to add to the picture.
I mentioned it in passing but it's very important.
One of the things class this does and he has to do it through measures passed
through the assembly is to enfranchise the people who had been thrown off the
citizen lists.
And one thing that you want to do.
You couldn't have done that given the nature of the old constitution if you
hadn't broken up the old system of tribes fruit trees and so on and come up with
a new one which would not have the old prejudices against it.
So that's part of the story.
Again Aristotle or one of his pupils there's some dispute about the document
that is called Athenian pull a tail.
Constitution of Athens as to whether Aristotle was the composer of that piece or
one of his students.
Anyway here's what it says.
What the aim of mixing up the population so that a great number would share in
the citizenship they came up with this phrase may follow Cree name do not judge
according to tribe.
But it goes beyond tribe it merely means do not judge on the basis of birth.
Aristotle says it was directed against those who wanted to check on family
backgrounds.
He goes on to say this new nomenclature that's what I just mentioned to you
before about your name is now no longer the son of you.
You are the son of a so and so but rather you are of the Dean.
So and so he says so that they would not by addressing one another by their
fathers names expose the newly enrolled citizens but would call them by the
families of the D.
This passage caused a great deal of puzzle and confusion among scholars who
couldn't understand what this is all about.
And that's I think because the topic was mostly treated by by the British but
Americans can see this right away.
If you were the best way to put it this way of course you wouldn't know about
this.
You live in a country with absolutely pure and without prejudice according to
race or color or ethnic origins or religion.
So you won't know what I'm talking about but let me pass on from an earlier
generation a darker time in which I grew up in which.
Supposing you were a man who came from the RNC in Italy and your name was
Giovanni DiStefano that was fighting in the Abruzzo but in America there were
people who didn't have a high opinion of people with such a name and were likely
not to be opening their doors or homes to people like that.
And so your son instead of calling himself.
Giovanni DiStefano changed his name to John Stevens
and thereupon everything was OK.
That's the way things were meant to be in Athens.
That is to say the idea was if you had a foreign sounding name your father would
have a foreign sounding name.
If he came from a foreign place when he settled in Attica you would be branded
in that way.
And people who wanted and here it was more specific who people who at some time
I want to throw you off the citizenships lists would know who you were.
But if you took a good solid Anglo Athenian name why you'd be all right.
So I think that is the explanation and it's all part of the same picture taking
away the traditional influences that would be an anti-democratic and replacing
them with things that shatter that and taking away the local powers.
Anything that smacked of the past.
You try to a race as best you can.
The procedure.
We all agree is by the device that the Greeks called Safe is mine.
It was a motion passed by the Assembly and it comes to be the standard form of
legislation in the Athenian democracy.
The plural of safe is my is safest my top.
Now the scholar who I was alluding to a few moments ago.
LEWIS He's got the general picture right.
He says we have to understand all of this was passed on the assembly and a mood
of great excitement and fear and anger.
A revolutionary situation in which he imagined alluding to the revolution in St.
Petersburg in 1917 that they are getting up and shouting all power to the ten
tribes.
To those of you who are not in St.
Petersburg but they were shouting was all power to the Soviets.
But I think he's wrong.
It wasn't about the ten tribes the ten tribes weren't the issue.
I think if they were shouting and I guess they were they were shouting all power
to the clay C.R.
to the assembly that's where decisions were going to be made in the future.
But I do want you to take seriously the notion of the making such a claim and
doing so in heated circumstances that are revolutionary because without that
it's inconceivable that what happened would have happened.
Now let me go back to the bullet.
It was elected by lot from proportional representation in the deans all of the
unions.
Greek word for preparing legislation for an assembly is pro Boone loosest and
such a group is called Pro Bowl Lutnick.
That is it prepares legislation
the chances are that this council was more powerful and had more independence
when it was invented than it would later on.
That's just a guess.
But you know you at the beginning of something there's still you're still living
in a society in which class distinctions are very clear and very sharp in which
the idea of the ordinary citizen taking things into his own hands is new and
scary.
I think that would have been a lot of deference paid to the individuals who came
from the higher classes and I would guess that they would have been on the list
preliminary list that that was elected before allotment selected among them.
And that when they proposed something to the assembly it would be given greater
sort of greater influence on what happened subsequently than would be true when
we get down to the full scale Athenian democracy in the time of Pericles.
Forget about it.
The bully is the servant of the assembly.
Without question the assembly can if if the if the council sends in a proposed
law and certain language the assembly can vote it down or they can send it back
to the bully and say no we don't like those words change the words into this
direction and send it back to us.
That's the way it was in the full democracy.
My guess is it wasn't that way in the year five or five.
I think it probably was meant by Kleist and these to be a bit more conservative
without being of course in any way reactionary.
Now what is this all about in the largest sense
Lewis suggests that there's something here that is personal and political and I
think he's right.
One of the elements that he suggests is these dreams were not assigned to
treaties accidentally as I've suggested already but were carefully laid out not
only to deprive noblemen of their undue influence but he thinks probably to help
close the knees and his alchemy on the die to have a powerful voice and as much
of Attica as he possibly could.
Why in the world would anybody doubt that.
That strikes me as being so I mean that's what people do when they have the
power to help themselves politically they do.
I would guess in other words Kleist in was thinking of his own political
position in part.
We don't have hard evidence for this but just a reasonable suggestion.
Now the other thing is we have to we have to I think believe that the this whole
program of reform was supported by what we have been referring to all along the
hop like class.
These independent farmers they are the ones who are most numerous.
They are.
I mean among those who will be politically active also they are of course the
defense of Athens.
Now they have to be taken very seriously and they are not about to allow
themselves to be cut out.
Or to have their own influence diminished by things that are hanging over from
the days of aristocracy.
And so I think we should think of this most scholars.
I think just about everybody does this.
They like to designate this place authentic democracy.
This first democracy as a hop light democracy and saying that the hot lights are
in means that to some considerable degree the poor are out.
The chances are very great.
I would say pretty certain that.
The majority of citizens.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Majority of Athenian citizens were not hotlines.
They were thieves
it probably never was a time when the hot lights were a majority even in Athens
so excluding them certainly is a limit on what you want to call democracy.
And here's where we get into sort of the debates these days.
Many many the scholar now that the.
The academy is essentially a branch of the Politburo
will want to denigrate ancient Athenian democracy and to suggest it really
wasn't democratic.
Well 20 million ways you can do that.
You can talk about the fact that it excluded women you can talk about the fact
that it
who else is it excluded slate.
That it had slaves excluded slaves it excluded resident aliens.
And all those things and then you can finally point to the fact that probably
the majority of the adult male citizens were excluded from some important
elements in the democracy although as time passes that last disappears and you
have pretty much complete participation by the poor.
But in Kleist in his case that's not so.
But I think that's to be deliberately blind to what's really happening.
What you have is a miracle nothing in the world that we know of anywhere.
Everything like this has ever been seen before.
The reaction of the other Greeks as best we can figure out was horror.
This is wild and crazy the stuff that the Athenians are doing.
It is radical it is dangerous.
We must contain ourselves and avoid being in touch with them.
But what we should try to finish those guys off.
Certainly that was the attitude the Spartans typically had towards it and
undoubtedly the normal Greek government which was in an oligarchy.
Certainly took the same point of view.
So I think you can look at it from either direction probably should look at him
from both.
But don't miss the point that what's happening here is of this very special
character.
What did they call this constitution.
Well we don't know yet but the chances are great that they did not call it
democracy.
The word democracy our democracy comes from the Greek democratic.
Which I guess you would want to translate is something like power.
For.
The masses for the people at large for the people as a whole.
But it was a name that was given to the Athenian constitution by people who
didn't like it.
Why did they think of themselves.
Well Robert this refers to this regime as one of these so no media
equality of law.
Oh and I think the thing that's most important about is equality before the law.
That is something that wipes out distinctions among classes of people on the
basis that it when it comes to the law.
Every man who comes before the law is equal to every other man.
Well that's a very big change that no place else in the world had.
And I think that's not a bad way to think of it.
And one of the principles that belong from the first to this democracy and was
maybe as crucial as anything in characterizing it was what they called you say
go read equality but equality of speech really meant equality of the opportunity
to address the political body meaning the assembly.
Every Athenian male from the first adult who was regardless of what his money
rating was of his class whether he was feet or higher.
Everyone had the right to speak in the assembly.
Now this had been a right that was limited of course to aristocrats in many
cities or to the wealthy in other cities.
But we know from the some of the poems in the fifth and the sixth century it was
prized as the evidence that an individual was a free man as opposed to a slave.
He could get up in the center.
That was the term they use of the town meaning where the meeting place was and
then speak his mind and also try to persuade his fellow citizens to do as he
thought best.
We should not take this lightly in our world where we never imagined ourselves
in such a situation.
It's hard to grasp but actually to think if I want to I can get out there during
the debate that's going to decide what happens and I can say what I have to say.
So freedom of speech very very central to
to the Athenian idea of self-government.
The role of the ballet in place of aristocratic councils enhances the democracy
there.
On the other hand things did not happen that you might think what happened.
Nothing was done in the sphere of the economy.
There was no change in slowness in classes or privileges.
You still had to have a certain amount of money to be elected to the top things
in the state.
The area of business was left untouched.
Remaining a collection of former magistrates all of whom had been aristocrats
the factories the home of aristocracy were left intact you had this hot light
democracy which was indeed democracy but we must imagine.
I think all the evidence would support this imagination that.
It was a deferential democracy in which the lower classes still looked up to the
upper classes for leadership and guidance and they themselves did not hold
leading positions in the state.
I think that's the picture we have.
Well let me try it last to one of the most to melt to my mind one of the most
interesting features of the Constitution introduced by Kleist and this gives us
a picture of how things worked that we wouldn't get any of any other way.
I'm talking about the law that was passed.
On ostracism.
Our word ostracism derives from it but it's something quite different.
If you somebody says we're going to ostracize this guy today it means we're not
going to invite him for a drink.
We're not going to go to his parties things like that.
Now this was something far different and was a central part of the political
system.
Let me begin by simply describing how it worked.
Every year let us say in the month of January that's the way the Italian
calendar would have made it come out more or less.
Typically a vote automatically came up a question came up in the assembly
automatically.
Nobody had to move it.
It was an automatic thing.
Question was shall we have an ostracism this year.
Now they could debate that question.
But what they were not debating was who should we ostracize.
That was not an issue.
The only prints question was Should we have one this year.
And if a majority said yes.
Then they would go on.
If the majority said no that was it no ostracism that year.
But supposing a majority had voted for an ostracism.
Now we go to roughly the month of March and let's go down to the centre of town
the Agora which is the marketplace which is the political centre which is where
people go to talk and all those things.
That's where the action is.
And for that day in that day alone.
The Agora is fenced off and there are 10 gates in the fences one for each tribe.
And
every citizen who wishes goes with a piece of broken pottery.
Someone has described it as the scrap paper of antiquity.
And with whatever you could get a piece of glass crayon or whatever you would
simply write the name of a man that you would like to see ostracized.
That year you would go to the gate.
There would be some but people at the gate who would would identify you really
as citizen where you come in.
You handed in your Astrakhan and you went inside the eagle rock where you stayed
until the voting was over so that you couldn't come back and vote again.
They were cleverer than the people of Florida are today.
So now it's over.
The time has come.
And what they do is they divide up all the obstacles that have been cast and
they don't divide them up.
I'm sorry they put them in a big pile and counting.
If there are fewer than 6000 ballots nobody gets ostracized
if there are six thousand or more.
Now they divide them up into piles and the one who gets the most votes not
majority.
Just the highest number of votes plurality he wins
he gets ostracized.
What does that mean.
It means that he must leave Attica for at a certain distance from Attica to for
10 years.
That's all he has been accused of no crime.
Therefore he has been convicted of no crime.
Nothing is done to his property.
Nothing is done to his family.
At the end of 10 years he may come back.
And it's as though he never left.
The next day if he wants to we can run for public office that's all that is
ostracism.
What's this all about.
What are the purposes of this thing.
Well I think the best way to come at this is to tell you a couple of stories and
some facts.
The story I guess comes from Plutarch life of Arab Studies who is one of the
leading Athenian figures at the early part of the fifth century and who in fact.
Was a man who was ultimately ostracized.
The story goes like this.
It's ostracism day in Athens and some country bumpkin some rube comes walking up
and he spots outside is chatting with some folks and he goes up to reciting says
Excuse me sir.
I don't know how to write would you please write a name on this shirt for me.
I recite is of course a gentleman.
He says suddenly Sir what name would you like.
He said the Arab state is please oh he says write down every.
And by the way said What is it that you have against Arab state.
I should have told you that Arab Studies had earned the sobriquet the just Arab
state is that just so the guy says Well what have you got against them.
I have nothing against the.
I've never seen the man don't know I'm just so damn tired of hearing him called
the just.
The point of that story is to illustrate Plutarch point is that
the system of ostracism was just a piece of silly foolishness that you would
associate with democracy which just allowed the jealousy of the ordinary man for
superior people to determine what's going on.
That's the message that Plutarch gets from that tale.
Here's another piece of information that's not a tale.
I think it's about 1937 38 an American archaeologist was working up on on the
north slope of the Acropolis and he came upon a well he dug into the well and
out came one hundred and ninety one inscribed punctures Astrakhan
but one name written on all of them and that name was Mr. Cleese who we know was
a participant in a batch of Astrakhan and the for a ostracism and for a and
careful analysis of the handwriting indicated that these one hundred and ninety
one Austria were inscribed by 14 hands writing them begins to sound familiar.
You guys I suppose is the best guess of everybody who studies these things is
that we do not have here the remains of a collection of voters who voted and had
their votes counted and then these came but rather that these were votes that
never were cast actually
so what's going on here.
Now I turned from my attempt at a factual account of what happened in the past
to fiction.
The rest of this is my imagination.
And we find ourselves down the middle of Athens the day before the ostracism.
We are in the home of John Potter.
Who is a charter member of the Arab state his political club
and what they are doing is sitting about chatting as they in size or paint the
name on to a Astrakhan.
The name is to mystically next day down there outside the agora.
Various country bumpkins and others wandering into town and you step up to one
of them and say perhaps you would like to vote in the ostracism today sir.
I can save you the trouble of inscribe in your ballot.
Here's one right now.
I think this is pretty good evidence that we're talking about organized
political activities which in fact I think totally squares with what we know
about the purpose of ostracism.
I should tell you one other thing that Cincinnati's himself says something very
important about this.
He says ostracism was brought about because of the fear and the insecurity that
the Athenians felt about their democracy that it was in constant danger and that
they needed something to help them.
That's the context in which he views it Plutarch as I say has a more general
story the envy and jealousy natural to democracy.
You must have realized that hardly anybody whoever wrote anything in antiquity
had a kind word to say for democracy.
It is a it's a bad thing from the standpoint of most of the authors of antiquity
but the facilities was there while ostracism was a reality as opposed to
Plutarch and I'm sure he is right.
Let's look.
First of all at the moment when ostracism was invented in the time of Kleist
Denise.
And before we move beyond that what's the situation.
Close the knees and company have just brought about this unique amazing end to
the rest of the world.
Dangerous cold data an invented this new wild crazy kind of government they
know.
That the Spartans are furious and they expect they're going to come down
anytime.
They also know that in Athens there are people who don't like this new
government.
Some of them are the heirs to the old aristocracy.
Some of them are aristocrats themselves.
Others were very happy in the days of the tyranny.
In fact there are still relatives of the tyrants eminent ones who are still in
Athens.
In other words they have to fear
betrayal.
They have to fear internal hostility they have to fear people might start a
civil war.
At the same time as they have to be afraid of the Spartans coming up the road
and we know because in a few years this is going to happen.
They have enemies of other neighboring states Corinthians directorates.
Others will be oceans thieves and within the next five years they will have.
Invasions by those people as well.
That's their situation.
What are they afraid of.
They are afraid that there will be treason inside the city which will help
invaders or simply turn the city over to them.
Well then why don't they just lock these guys up.
Well the first place they probably haven't done anything yet.
And you couldn't make a case against them.
On top of which you really don't if you're clean Sunnis you don't want to treat
all of these people as though they are the enemies of the new regime.
They are in fact natural opponents.
That's the Friends of the tyrants and the old aristocrats.
They're on opposite sides of the argument.
Why would you want to put them together by assaulting their leaders.
A smarter thing would be to try to win over.
One faction to support of your side at the expense of the other.
And that is my guess as to what is another explanation of what's happening here.
So here's another piece of fiction I want to throw at you.
I imagine that Kleist in these stops by at the house of his parkas the son of
Khamis who is a distant relative of the pious districts and who would be looked
to as the leading figure in that faction and.
He stopped by the sea.
Park and Hyde Park this is a low class and they say What is this routine.
What is this crazy new law that you and your boys just put through this
ostracism law.
I hear in the streets that it's aimed at me as the leader of the old terrorist
faction.
What is that in these I imagine would say.
Now where did you get a crazy idea like that.
I mean that's you're a swell fellow.
I'm only against these terrible risk those out there in this Spartan lackeys
that we're going to take away all the people's rights and I know you wouldn't
want that to happen would be good.
That's not like you.
So of course I can see your point.
I can see you are alarmed.
I can see that people might say gee those old hype the past history these people
might be trying to overthrow this new democracy and bring themselves back in.
I know hippie is over there in Persia supported by the king and maybe people
would thank you for bringing him back as a tyrant.
I know that would never be in your mind.
But I tell you what you ought to do.
Why don't you come over to my side and I'll see to it.
You know I have friends I got a lot of friends I could do you a favor
you do me a favor I could do you a favor I could see that I would just kill that
rumor and everything would be very happy next day all as well.
And I think there's considerable evidence I don't have time for it now.
Not not certain but evidence suggesting that Marcus came on board and became
part of a coalition that ruled Athens for decades after that time.
And so that year there was no ostracism because they didn't have to be in
ostracism.
I think that is very important.
Most years there was no ostracism only once in a while.
And every single person that we hear ostracized was a leading political figure
ostracism ensure it was meant to be a constitutional device to work in the
political realm as a way of deterring a coup de Tau treason or other forms of
unrest.
You could only use it as a politician if you were the popular favorite if you
were confident that the ostracism would go your way if you held in ostracism and
that wasn't true.
You might find yourself traveling a long way from home pretty soon.
And so that's the essence of ostracism.
And we'll have a look at it again because it crops up and is used but not for 20
years after it's invented.
OK.